Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to the
"Ghost Pepper of Commitment"
I have something incredibly
Important that i'm gonna be telling you today that affects the entirety of my
..channel. But before I get started, I have to eat this ghost pepper
*Dramatic Danger Music*
[Ghost peppers don't have any different aromas than a normal cayenne pepper at all]
[besides having a texture like rubber and smell of citrus]
[But when they ingested their effects can be long lasting besides the immeasurable heat]
[Their Scoville Heat Unit can ramp up to 1 million easily]
[No need to say your intestines will get scorched as well upon consuming it]
..Okay...
[do not try this at home. I just hope Mark is not a fool and a good actor]
Okay, I'm gonna be going to be doing one video a day
you've already seen the results of this over the past week that i've been doing it because..
...because..
*salivating and panting*
because.. I..I over the past week I've been uploading
Every day at the exact same time with one video and the videos have been, longer than they have been before
HO MY Fah-CKING.. Gawd!
The videos have been longer than they have, before because I've been playing
whole games in a single video. It's because I believe in the days of..
... doing *gulp*
Videos...over and breaking them up to the part of the videos having them - da - knotting
in 15 - 30 minute parts is an old thing over when you couldn't...
....how...
(salivating and tries not to puke probably)
Videos be longer than a certain, amount of time in a certain amount of time
So I wanna play full games in certain videos
I want to compact a bunch of games into certain videos and the response has been great so far
because you guys *struggling* have-- seem-- to-..
*salivates and panting again*
You guys have seemed to have loved it, and that's super awesome
Thank you guys so much for understanding and it's been great support and also
I'll be uploading at exactly 11:00 A.M Pacific Standard Time, every single day, EVERY SINGLE DAY!
and I don't want to break that... hoooo... *panting*
They'll, be more gaming content than ever before because there's gonna be more in every video,
also there'll be more live-action, challenges
(oh no)
cool new videos, vlogs, cool stuff, and they'll be really
*crying and dying gorilla noises*
[at this moment whole heat reflects and emanates from his organs I think]
There'll be more cool, stuff that I'll be doing like
like that.. that one in the video where I was hanging in a safety harness. Full harness.
And that it was before challenges etcetera..
More live-action goofs. It'll be great and I am committing to this 100% I'm not gonna lie about this
one I'm committing to this 100%
oh I'm spitting everywhere
Committing to this 100% because if I don't..... upload
Every single day at the exact same time if I miss an upload for any single reason.
The reason this is called ghostpepper of commitment is because..
If I don't... IF I DON'T, I have to eat another ghost pepper, live! Wherever I am.. on livestream.
Wherever I am, If I miss a video I have to eat another ghost pepper and it doesn't matter!
Eugh I'm snotting so much
[He's hurting his gut flora. Someone speak some sense to him]
It doesn't matter where I am. Live, I would eat a ghost pepper on camera for you guys as punishment
and then I will resume the schedule every single day that I miss. If I miss more than one day
I have to eat a ghost pepper
...
.. everyday...
No matter where I am
And that's all
I got to...
[one moment pls]
~ All around me are familiar faces ~ (Mark suffers while we all watch)
~ worn out places ~ (Mark suffers even more....)
pain is only in the mind.....
everything... is relative
~ Worn..
~ Worn out..
~ Worn out fa--.. ~ (Mark why did you subject yourself to this pain???)
I'm really happy with the way I want to make videos
and I want to make better content for you, guys.
more better..
and this change is not something that comes easy
~ All around me are familiar... ~
[Back to reality]
It just gets worse. It just gets worse!
...It just gets WORSE!
*sniffle*
Find a happy place
[I just hope that's a huge act]
Ethan? *Milk decides to go splashy splashy on the floor*
I just want to make better content for you guys, is this...
is this better content?
is it?!
But this is why I'm committed to this I will stick to this schedule
Tell your friends tell everybody
I'm back and better than ever before and I'm gonna make so many cool videos in the future
Not all of them are gonna, be as stupid as this, some might even be stupider but you could guarantee
That there's not gonna be a single boring video on my channel so thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next video
Bye, bye!
[A toast for our fellow youtuber Mark. With a glass of milk.]
[Consider taking vitamin B, Mark. Jeeze.]